We have undertaken a historic effort to massively
reduce job-crushing regulations.
Sounded good to me,
but the media says Trump is wrecking America.
This is a very big deal.
The Environmental Protection Agency
just rolled back Obama-era climate rules.
He singlehandedly led the world down a dark path.
His proposal is literally insane.
We’re told his deregulation
is an attack on the environment,
that workers health, safety, and pay are casualties,
and even that Trump is trying to kill us.
Now Trump has cut regulations
This is where we were in 1960.
He promised to shrink the regulation rulebook
back to the size it was 58 years ago.
We will have a great regulatory climate.
One. Two. three.
[applause]
The day he got elected,
you saw the stock markets swing up.
Grover Norquist runs a group that
fights for lower taxes and fewer rules.
Trump sent a message to business:
we're not going to crush you, and that's caused growth.
That was the beginning of a recovery.
In the 48 hours since Donald Trump
was elected to the Oval Office,
the stock market has rallied, reaching new heights.
And the Trump administration has repealed lots of rules,
for example…
Waters of the United States.
We've got to protect waters of the United States.
Sounds good.
They were including little trickles,
the kind of ponds that spring up
when it rains a lot one night,
and then it goes away the next day.
They were using it as land control.
Land control can crush people.
Jill and Jack Barron were encouraged by Idaho officials
to clear a drainage ditch,
but when they did that,
federal officials went after them,
fining them thousands of dollars.
37,500 a day
Until the Barrons had to sell their home
and move into this trailer
But now thanks to deregulation,
they can use their land again. Good.
But other repealed rules sound important.
The names for all these regulations
are written by the regulators.
They're advertisements for themselves
But unlike many advertisers,
regulators don’t list the side effects
Some people have had changes in behavior,
hostility, agitation
May cause unemployment, may reduce wages,
may raise the cost of energy,
may make your car not drivable.
[CAR NOISE]
Well, its drivable, but smaller because the Obama rules
would have forced car makers
to nearly double gas mileage,
and more people are killed in smaller cars
Should the government tell you what kind of car to buy?
Should they? And that's what the regulation does.
Now California regulators have made a deal
with 4 automakers to keep the Obama rules,
in effect telling Californians,
some cars you cannot have.
Net neutrality for everyone
Trump’s FCC also ended “net neutrality” rules.
They were going to turn the internet,
which is a free, largely free, and open operation
into a government regulated utility monopoly
When Trump repealed that,
people said he was
Handing the keys to the internet over to a
handful of multi-billion-dollar corporations
Bad things were going to happen.
They were going to charge you to do this, that
and the other thing.
The companies would send your emails slower
than somebody else's.
None of that's happened.
None of it. None of it. None of it.
The 2 for $5 mix and match deal
from McDonald’s is back.
Many regulations were repealed
that few people know about.
One would’ve treated franchise companies
like McDonald’s as one single business.
Why? The trial lawyers want to be able
to sue all of McDonald’s,
not just the local McDonald’s,
if they spill coffee on themselves.
And the labor unions wanted to unionize
all of McDonald’s, not just the one store.
That would have been a disaster.
That was ended.
Deregulation. It’s when we remove those bad rules
so that corporations can maximize their profits. Ha ha!
People think Trump is destroying the workplace
and the environment.
If you get your news from late night comedy shows,
you think that deregulation is bad
for the economy and bad for the environment.
In point of fact it's good for the environment,
it's good for jobs,
it's good for people having more wealth.
But we want the air to be cleaner.
The air is getting cleaner. It's dramatically cleaner.
It is. Mostly because of EPA rules
passed decades ago...
and every time someone replaces
an old car with a new one the air gets a little cleaner.
Now climate change and whether we can do anything
about that is a separate debate,
but when it comes to clean air Trump’s
undoing of Obama’s ever-stricter standards
just returns us to the rules in effect
during the Clinton and Bush years.
Were you coughing then?
No, but the media won’t tell you that.
President Trump has liberated American factories
from the scourge of pollution rules.
[coughs]
Lost in the coughing is the unfortunate fact
that Trump is adding regulations too!
It’s all about “made in America”
Now government agencies have to buy
more American made stuff.
That sounds like a good idea,
but it's a dumb idea and I wish he hadn't done it.
That is not deregulation. That is regulation.
Stocks tumbling today
Markets that rose when he was elected
have dropped as Trump's tariffs
punishAmerican companies that buy steel
and consumers who want things like
washing machines and solar panels.
There is a challenge.
Trump is a protectionist in many ways.
And then I can always do much more
or I can do less,
depending on what happens with respect to a deal
and tariffs are taxes and regulations on the border,
are regulations on consumers,
and frankly it hasn’t cost our consumers anything.
It costs China.
The good news is,
the vast majority of the regulatory acts
by a factor of many have been deregulatory
and they have been tremendously helpful
And yet with all this publicity about Trump deregulating,
he hasn't done that much.
He's done a great deal more than anybody
in recent history, maybe even more than Reagan did.
We have cut 22 regulations
for every one new regulation.
Think of that one
He exaggerates, as usual.
The real number is about 5 repealed
for every new one passed.
But that’s still pretty good.
He’s loosened all these rules.
It’s good whenever excessive regulations are cut.
Regulations are like taxes.
They take choices away from ...
the government takes your money.
You don't get to decide what to do.
You have to go work more hours,
spend less time with your family,
less time of things you want to do.
They take your time.
[Thud]
They cost us money,
deprive us of opportunities,
[Thud]
they take our freedom.